what we're gonna be doing is just as a
sort of uh nice easy introduction is
just having a look at some of these
worked examples and uh they're not
they're not arduous if you know how to
differentiate and your understanding of
general protocol quotient is sound then
you'll eat these for breakfast however
if you're like actually mine is
definitely not sound i learned that in
the review questions this morning um
then these will be a little more
challenging and that's kind of why i
want to make sure we're on the same page
together okay so i've just picked out a
few from one and two and as you can see
we're going to go
far beyond that during our time to work
today but we'll get to those examples a
bit later on let's have a look at the
ones i've selected
first one j so it's over there y equals
2 sine
3
x
so if we are differentiating this
d
y
on dx let's just step through it one
step at a time
as with when we've been differentiating
polynomials if i gave you something like
say i'll do it over here you'd have to
write this if i gave you something like
um oops
messy sorry
if i gave you something like say 5 x
cubed
right what do you do with that five like
mentally what do you do with it
kind of just like
put it to one side for a minute right it
doesn't deeply affect what you are
differentiating so you kind of mentally
put that away
and then you focus on the other part of
it the x cubed right the x cubed of
course is
3x squared so you're like oh that 3x
squared i'm going to now combine it back
with that 5. so the way we would say
this is when you've got a constant
coefficient right at the front it
doesn't really affect your
differentiation 15x squared off you go
same deal here so this 2 we'll just
momentarily forget about it we'll come
back to it okay we're going to focus on
this sine
3x now we already know what the
derivative of regular old sine x is but
when we stick an extra number in here
what's going on
well this is a function sine
of another function
3x so we're gonna do with this what
we've been doing with function of a
function chain rule all along we'll
differentiate this bit
and then we'll differentiate the whole
thing okay
so can you tell me what's the derivative
of 3x
it's just 3 right
so i'm going to write that 3 right there
there's the inside derivative as it were
now the outside is sine
what does sine turn into
cos right so therefore
this is going to next be cause but it's
not cos of x it's because of
3x if you wrote the whole long chain
rule notation it would because of u like
you'd call this you'd call this u right
but i'm trying to be as succinct as i
can so i'm just saying okay well this is
cos of u which is 3x
you've done this part and now we need to
put back that 2 that we kind of forgot
about earlier on right so therefore this
part
is just going to give you 2
times that so final answer
6
cos 3x and you're finished i mean maybe
i'll just write it just here for
completeness 6 cos
3x so you can see there's the different
components you're doing each one at a
time let's look at t
the one that i've chosen for t
is
y equals 6 cos
x on 3.
i'm going to differentiate
6 cos x
on 3. let's see if we can do that same
series of steps but one at a time
i'm actually going to start it's a bit
weird right i'm going to start at the
end the exon 3 is the first thing that
we looked at here is 3x so what's the
derivative of that inside part x on 3.
[Applause]
derivative of x on 3. we could do that
right that's going to be
a third because i would write this as a
third times x so you're just going to
have a third
that cause is going to turn into just be
watchful cos turns into
negative sign when you differentiate it
so i'm going to write that as negative
sign but it's not
sine x it's sine of
x on three whatever was there before it
just sort of carries along right
and then the last piece of the puzzle is
that 6 that was hanging out the front
there right
so now noticing that i've got the six
the third and the minus and you put them
all together you'll get
negative two and then the rest of it
is that okay